ADMIT THAT HANNA GATSBY IS NOT
FUNNY.
>> HIS SPECIAL IS CALLED "THE
CLOSER," HE JOKED ABOUT TRANS
WOMEN'S GENITALES.
HE OFFENDED MANY PEOPLE.
JOINING ME NOW, YOU OFFENDED A
LOT OF PEOPLE IN YOUR COMEDY
EVERY, KAMU BELL.
GOOD TO SEE YOU, I AM GLAD TO
HEAR YOUR PERSPECTIVE.
FIRST OF ALL, TELL ME WHAT YOU
THINK BEFORE I ASK ALL THESE
QUESTIONS?
>> WHAT DO I THINK?
THERE ARE SO MANY THINGS TO
THINK ABOUT THIS.
I THINK THAT THE THING ABOUT
STAND-UP COMMOEDY IS ONE-WAY
TRAFFIC.
HE GETS TO SAY WHATEVER AND HE
GETS TO SET THE TERMS OF THE
DEBATE.
HE CAN SHIFT THE DEBATE.
YONNI OF THE TRANS PEOPLE OR
NETFLIX IS ASKING TO MEET WITH
DAVE SCHAPPELLE.
NOW HE SAID IT -
>> AFTER ALL THE BACKLASH, HE
SAYS HE WANTS TO SET THE
CONDITIONS ON HEARING OUT FROM
THE TRANS KMIECOMMUNITY.
THE REAL DIVIDE IS BETWEEN HIM
AND CORPORATE AMERICA.
HE THINKS CORPORATE AMERICA
SHOULD STOP BOWING TO INTERESTS,
WHAT DID YOU THINK ABOUT THAT?
>> CORPORATE AMERICA DID NOT BOW
TO INTERESTS.
I DON'T KNOW IF BLACK PEOPLE
WOULD HAVE THE FREEDOM TO ENJOY
IN THIS COUNTRY, FIRST OF ALL.
>> THIS IS NOT ABOUT CORPORATE
AMERICA BOW TO INTERESTS.
I KNOW HE SAYS HE'S BEEN
CANCELLED OR DEEMED CANCELLED.
I WOULD LIKE TO CANCEL DAVE
CHAPPELLE.
HE GOTTEN $20 MILLION FOR HIS
LAST FEW SPECIALS.
I DON'T THINK HE'S CANCELLED.
HE'S COURTING THIS CANCEL
CULTURE BECAUSE IT'S A MARK.
WHAT DID YOU THINK OF HIS
SPECIAL AND HOW DO WE CREATE A
SAFER AMERICA FOR TRANS PEOPLE?
NOW, THE DAVE CHAPPELLE'S
SPECIAL MAY BE APART OF THAT
CONVERSATION BUT NOT THE MAIN
PART OF THAT CONVERSATION.
>> I SAID TO YOU AND I AM SURE
YOU OFFENDED PEOPLE WITH YOUR
COMEDY, DO YOU THINK YOU OFFEND
PEOPLE?
>> OF COURSE I OFFEND PEOPLE.
THE IDEA OF PUNCHING UP AND
DOWN.
THAT'S AN IDEA THAT I BELIEVE
IN.
I WANTED TO OFFEND THE PEOPLE
WHO I THINK IS OKAY OR SHOULD BE
OFFENDED.
THAT'S HOW I ROLL.
NOT EVERY COMICS WORK THAT WAY.
ONCE YOU OFFEND PEOPLE, YOU HAVE
TO DEAL WITH THE CONSEQUENCES
AND RIGHT NOW DAVE CHAPPELLE IS
HEARING FROM PEOPLE.
NONE OF THE PEOPLE ON NETFLIX
ARE SAYING TAKE HIS SPECIAL
DOWN.
WE WANT YOU TO CREATE AN
ENVIRONMENT WHERE WE CAN FEEL
SAFER AND LISTEN TO.
>> THERE IS ALSO THIS UNDERLYING
TENSION BETWEEN BLACK GENDER AND
HETEROSEXUAL MEN, LAST SEASON ON
YOUR KNOW "UNITED SHADES," YOU
SPOKE TO PEOPLE WHAT THEY CAN DO
BETTER.
>> IF I AM NOT HURTING ANYBODY
OR KILLING ANYBODY, I AM DOING
ENOUGH.
OBVIOUSLY WE CAN DO MORE.
WHAT CAN MEN LIKE ME DO BETTER?
>> LET ME ASK YOU.
HOW DO YOU THINK WE ALL LIVE?
>> THE HARDEST THING TO DO IS
TELLING A HETEROSEXUAL MAN TO
SHUT-UP.
>> THAT STUFF HAPPENS MORE OFTEN
AND EASY TO LET GO AND OH, I AM
NOT GOING TO GET INVOLVED IN
THIS.
>> IT'S NOT LOCKER ROOM TALK,
IT'S VIOLENCE AND PEOPLE GETTING
KILLED.
>> IT'S VIOLENCE WHEN WE ARE
ABLE TO LAUGH AT SOMEBODY ELSE'S
HUMANITY BEING TAKEN AWAY FROM
THEM.
THAT WAS NOT THE PHYSICAL ACT OF
VIOLENCE BUT IT WAS THE
PRECURSOR TO THE PHYSICAL ACT OF
VIOLENCE.
IT'S OKAY TO THE MIND OF THE
PERSON WHO MAY GO AND DO THAT
THING OR THE MIND OF A PERSON
WHO HAS A CHILD THAT WOULD GO
AND DO THAT THING.
>> WHAT WOULD YOU TELL DAVE
CHAPPELLE AND WHY SHOULD HE DO
THE SAME?
>> I THINK IF HE REALLY WANTS TO
HAVE A CONVERSATION WITH THE
TRANS COMMUNITY, SPECIFICALLY
THE BLACK TRANS COMMUNITY.
HE WAS INCLUDING BLACK TRANS
FOLKS IN THE COMMUNITY AND
DEALING WITH THE WEIGHT OF BLACK
IN AMERICA AND BEING TRANS.
I DON'T THINK YOU DO THAT BY
TELLING THEM YOU ARE GOING SET
THE DATE AND TIME, YOU WANT THE
CONVERSATION TO COME TO YOU.
IF YOU WANT TO HAVE A
CONVERSATION, YOU GO TO THEM.
I WENT TO DALLAS, THAT WAS THE
HOUSE OF REBIRTH, I MET WITH
POCAHONTAS AND WE SAT AND HAD A
CONVERSATION.
ONE OF THE HARDEST THINGS TO DO
IS SHUT OUR MOUTH AND LISTEN.
THAT'S WHAT I GOTTEN GOOD AT IS
SHUT YOUR MOUTH AND LISTENING.
THAT'S NOT SOMETHING EVERYBODY
PERSON OR COMICS WANT TO DO.
YOU CAN SEE MY DISCOMFORT.
THEY SAID YOU HAVE TO BE WILLING
TO CALL OUT BLACK SEGENDER MEN.
THAT'S STILL DIFFICULT.
I AM TALKING TO YOU ABOUT DAVE
CHAPPELLE, I HAVE OFFENDED THE
GOAT.
I WANT YOU TO CREATE A WORLD
THAT'S EMPATHETIC FOR TRANS
PEOPLE AND SPECIFICALLY BLACK
TRANS WOMEN.
>>>.
>> JUST ABOUT YOU COMING ON AND
BOTH OF YOU SAID, MAN, I DON'T
KNOW WHAT TO DO WITH THIS
CONVERSATION, IT COULD BE
EXHAUSTING.
IT'S IMPORTANT BUT YOU KNOW
EVERYBODY FEELS A CERTAIN WAY
AND EVERYBODY IS GOING TO SAY
SOMETHING AND IS THERE IS
ANYTHING THAT YOU DIDN'T SAY
M
KAMAU?
I REALLY RESPECT YOUR
PERSPECTIVE.
>> WHEN I WATCHED CHAPPELLE'S
SPECIAL, IT SORT OF BUMS ME OUT
BECAUSE I KNEW ONCE AGAIN IT'S
THE FANS OF CHAPPELLE AND THE
PEOPLE WHO STAND WITH CHAPPELLE.
WE HAVE SEEN PEOPLE ON THE RIGHT
WEAPONIZING CHAPPELLE'S WORDS
AGAINST THE TRANS COMMUNITY.
THAT CREATES LESS SAFETY FOR
TRANS PEOPLE AND SPECIFICALLY
FOR BLACK TRANS FOLKS.
DAVE ON "SNL" TRUMP WAS ELECTED
HE SAID "GIVE HIM A CHANCE" AND
LATER HE CAME BACK AND SAID
"OOPS."
YOU DON'T WANT YOUR JOKES TO